从我们自己的经验来看的话，
他不会越变越好，
只会越来越那啥和我对象之间的问题吧，
我想咨询你一下，
就说间解，
可以帮我分析一下，
就今年是28岁，
工资的话是1万左右，
长相的话其实还行吧，
我对象的话，
他比我大6岁，
也是34岁，
他是做生意的，
收入的话不太稳定，
差不多50左右吧一年，
这业的话也是一个稳步上升的一个阶段，
我俩现在是异地，
但是他其实也可以回来，
就一个月的话，
最少就是能在家十天，
我俩现在就有两个问题吧，
第一个的话就是我觉得他有一点就是那种逃避型的人格，
有事情的话我想让他给我解决，
因为我是那种有啥直说的人，
我俩之间有争吵或者有问题我想让他给我解决，
就有点那种想要逃避的状态，
就是每次都是把我逼极，
一个人崩溃了之后，
谈不下去之后，
他就才来找我解决这个问题，
然后第二点就是那方面的生活，
他就是时间最长的话就两分钟，
最短的话就几十秒，
我俩在一起两年多了，
就快三年了吧，
也看了有两年了，
就是一直没有什么特别大的进展，
我们也经常吵架，
所以说我就一直在纠结，
还要不要继续没孩子啊，
我俩现在处对象呢，
已经在一起在就是两年多了，
咱们就说本身的这样一个需求，
你以前也谈过男朋友是吧，
以前也谈过对象，
就是一个比较正常的状态，
不是说是很那个啥，
那你能接纳他的这种现状嘛，
就是如果以后没有改善，
你能接纳。
了，
感觉不太新，
那不行，
那就算了，
那别勉强，
那现在我俩也是就入这讨论这个问题，
就我们还要不要再继续了，
因为如果说他跟你啊，
在你28岁那么年轻，
那么鲜活，
身材还这么好的时候，
如果他都是这样一个表现的话，
等将来相处时间长了，
新鲜劲儿过了，
彼此之间那方面的吸引力下降了，
包括有了孩子了，
身材走样了，
那他对你更没想法，
啥想法没有，
只会越来越差，
不会越来越好，
我直播间有没有吧，
你自己以前没明白这事儿啊，
或者你结了婚生了孩子了之后，
你明白这事儿了，
就如果说在你俩谈恋爱的时候，
初期是两个人最美好的状态，
你这块越年轻啊，
体格子越好，
是最美好的状态，
如果说他都这样的话，
那到后面只会越来越差，
不会越来越好，
只会越来越没兴趣，
没感觉，
没想法啊，
越来越差，
因为我不太懂这方面啊，
如果说去看的话，
这个会不会，
那我觉得首先给他自己，
给他自己重视这个事儿，
他自己愿意配合起他自己，
这方面他不自卑，
他不暴怒，
有的人是你一说让他去看，
看了，
他觉得可上面子了，
就暴怒，
就自卑，
那就没法处，
有的人她很积极，
很客观，
老天爷给了我一个弱身板儿，
那我要好好的爱我的女人，
我想要去配合我，
这个事儿又不是我的错，
我也不觉得有什么丢面子，
我也不觉得去看医生有什么大不了的，
我就积极。
和面对也有这样式，
你要遇到那样式儿的，
他愿意积极去面对，
去改善，
去健身，
去戒酒，
去戒烟，
你补铁，
就那个啥调整可以有指望，
如果题是也有在健身吃药，
然后一直都在吃，
但是效果并不是很明显，
那你自己看了啊，
从我们自己的经验来看的话，
她不会越变越好，
只会越来越那啥姑娘啊，
我说句题外话，
就是接纳自己的诉求，
其实你知道吗？
有很多女孩子她是很希望找一个没啥想法的人，
很希望找一个这方面没有太多想欲望的人，
就把你这个男的留给那些女孩子，
和他俩能幸福的过一辈子是真的，
我直播间应该也有吧，
你确实没啥想法，
他如果说一年他不找你的话，
你觉得挺好，
大家相信如宾一起吃个饭，
一起做个菜，
一起看看电影，
一起聊聊天挺好，
有没有吗？
直面自己的内心，
接纳自己的欲望渴望，
是这意思，
好的，
我再考虑一下吧，
拜拜，
而且我跟你说，
我们女人啊，
就分阶段，
你像到了四五十岁，
尤其是生了两个孩子，
三个孩子之后的，
咱们的女性的话，
可能有一部分的女性，
她就千万别找我是吧，
大家就吃吃饭，
聊聊天，
散散步就很好了，
千万别找我，
是分人啊，
也分阶段，
就像刚才你的那个男的，
她如果找一个二十几岁的时候就没啥想法，
他喜欢柏拉图式的相处的。
那他俩就能过很好，
他俩就能过挺平静，
挺幸福，
也不会有自卑，
也不会有那啥，
你看我直播间很多女人都有这种体会嘛，
是吧，
就是不同的人他有不同的诉求，
那我们生而为人，
最主要的一点就是要清醒的看到我自己的诉求，
并且也接纳我自己的内心的渴望，
找到那个匹配的适合的人。
记得点赞关注哦。